[Musique]
toujours un vrai numéro d'équilibriste
de poser la caméra comme ça regardez je
vous montre alors on parle de ce
smartphone aujourd'hui j'en profite je
montre un peu les queens à new york pour
quelques jours regardez regardez
regardez voilà sur quoi je me pose je le
pose là dessus faut vraiment pas que ça
bouge parce que sinon ça va pas le faire
on est donc aujourd'hui là pour parler
de ce nouveau smartphone cas là dedans
alors pas exactement comme vous le voyez
faujour les blackhawks nouveau
smartphone d'asus c'est le zinc phone 9
alors les iphone 9 il est petit il est
compact il est mignon et surtout les une
vraie particularité c'est chepalova re
parler un peu du marché très rapidement
des smartphones à jussie sorte de
smartphones par enfin réellement 1 c'est
celui là c'est le iphone c'est le
flexible c'est le gros smartphone d'asus
l'autre qui sort ce seuil dans la gamme
rog asus rog on a connu l'europe phone
je vous ai présenté il ya pas très
longtemps c'est du gaming c'est très à
paris est super bon rang de fun pour les
1000 va être très bon pour jouer tous
les accessoires en termes de photos il
est un peu aux fraises celui là il a une
particularité et pour réussir à se faire
de la place dans les rayons pour essayer
un stade la place pour réussir à ce
qu'on vienne l'acheter et bien c'est le
format il est tout petit si vous
regardez un peu dans le passé l'année
dernière et avant il avait sorti un flip
avec une caméra sony qui montait la qui
sortait et vous aviez une super caméra à
l'avant comme à l'arrière c'était le
flip c'est marrant sauf que je pense que
philippe ils n'ont pas vendu des caisses
et ils sont dit qu'est-ce qu'on peut
venir faire pour que les gens viennent
acheter aux smartphones et bien les
écrans vais de plus en plus grands les
smartphones deviennent de plus en plus
grand bain non affaire inverse on va
sortir un petit smartphone donc un
smartphone qui se tient facilement dans
l'âme un smartphone qu'on ne galère pas
à bien prendre comme ça avec quelques
idées assez maligne et c'est ce qu'on
avait déjà une âme hier avec le jeune
feuilleter ce qu'on retrouve là encore
plus cette année avec le sinn fein donc
le zinc fond des filets coulissants
jolies promesses qui vont pendant le dso
mais par contre ceux et celles qui
veulent un petit smartphone mignot très
sympa alors y'a du rouge mais y'a pas
que du rouge eh bien mon pouvoir
potentiellement craquer là dessus et ça
s'est joué
regarder à côté de quoi j'ai pris mon
hôtel en gros on vous assure j'ai avec
ce patch tuesday
vous emmène à madison square park à new
york et alors ils ont un corner spécial
chiens ou vous avez les maîtres les
chiens qu'ils aient eu foule entre eux
et le reste du parcours on peut venir
s'amuser et qui globalement on n'a rien
à voir donc ça c'est plutôt sympa et ça
c'est très différent parce qu'en france
on l'a pas donc les crottes de chien
elles sont là et puis le reste du parc
il est partout des gens commencent à se
parler un peu du design design qui est
un peu différent de ce qu'on va
retrouver alors ils ont tous sont venus
bossé ils ont amélioré certaines choses
à commencer par des angles là ils vous
ont mis des angles arrondis alors l'idée
des angles arrondis c'est de changer un
petit peu le design est d'apporter
légèrement autre chose dit bien
légèrement parce que c'est pas non plus
énorme sur tout c'est ici toute la
partie photo qui va être beaucoup plus
grande ici on des 40% plus grand que ce
qu'on avait sur les iphone 8 heures
c'est pas mal parce que celle ci donne
un peu de la gueule moi j'aime bien je
me sens vraiment franchement sympa ça
vous fait des espèces de grands vieux
comme ça je veux dire le superposer à ma
tronche effet d'espèces de deux grands
yeux bonjour aux petites écuries qui est
en train de se balader la barca c'est la
joue à new york on a des écureuils de
partout donc là vous avez ces espèces de
gours deux rendu alors là la couleur
j'ai effectivement passés au rouge il
existe en rouge en blanc en bleu et en
noir comme ça surtout oddo vous avez un
nouveau matériau alors quand on le
regarde comme ça je sais pas quoi ça
vous fait penser il ya une espèce de
côté un peu touché c'est pas une espèce
de faux cuir c'est pas vrai du tout
était pensé d'espèces de microfibres en
fait je pense que ça matériaux en
plastique et en coûte un peu moins cher
toute la structure que vous avez là elle
est bien évidemment totalement en
aluminium et surtout pratiquement c'est
que le bouton là qui vous sert pour
venir déverrouiller qui sert de capteur
d'empreintes digitales c'est le zen
touch 2 tonnes qui a différentes
fonctionnalités et se jauge button c'est
un des vrais intérêts que vous allez
retrouver sur ce smartphone ya un truc
un peu différent je vous montre comment
ça marche en fait c'est zen touch 2
tonnes il va vous servir à plusieurs
choses déjà lorsqu'il est fermé
forcément ça fait capteur d'empreintes
digitales hop là j'étais comme ça
j'appuie se déverrouille et surtout
celles d'autres fonctionnalités c'est
qu'en fait vous avez un petit slide en
fonction de ce que vous allez faire
regardez par exemple je vais saïd
également voyez ça ne bouge ça voyez je
re slide en cavale bas et là je navigue
alors je suis un peu dans une posture un
peu la rage sur un bord new york donc
m'en voulez pas pour le truc mais je
cela il jure slide et je navigue en fait
ça c'est assez marrant à l'agefi le
monde waka slide et dessus c'est un peu
le truc faire gaffe parce que ça se fait
très facilement dans vos paramètres vous
venez d'en avancer dans avance et vous
verrez dans smart qui est dans son parti
faisait plusieurs choses déjà vous
pouvez appuyer deux fois dessus tant que
je puis deux fois dessus ça m'allume la
torche 100 d'accès rapide alors ça peut
allumer la toile ça peut faire ce que
vous voulez vraiment le choix dans vos
paramètres vous choisissez de paramétrer
comme vous voulez par défaut pour rien
l'assistant en très vocal et compagnie
ensuite vous pouvez appuyer maintenir
choisir vous venez paramétrer également
comme vous voulez avec ici la fonction
éteinte c'est ce que j'ai moi par défaut
et puis balayé c'est ça c'est ce petit
slide accès rapidement notification si
vous souhaitez regarder vous le monde
soit côté où il n'ya refaire aussi
différents trucs en fonction une fois de
plus de ce que vous voulez ça sert aussi
à naviguer c'est un petit truc qui est
assez mal en plus qu envoyer c'est pas
la grosse révolution mais ce que je
trouve très marrant ici c'est de se dire
que eh bien pourquoi est ce que j'irai
pas ajouter de nouvelles fonctionnalités
sur ce petit bouton là qui à la base est
juste un bouton qui sert à l'allumette à
l'éteindre ce capteur d'empreintes
digitales maintenant de smart qui voient
là le truc est malin le truc et marron
donc ça c'est chouette
alors soyons clair au niveau de l'écran
il n'y a pas grand chose qui change
aurait sur un tout petit écran on
regarde ici exactement la même recette
qu'on avait sur iphone huile
c'est-à-dire un écran 5,9 pause ça joue
le dit c'est du super amoled full hd
plus haut niveau de la résolution 445
cas pixels par pouce à ce gars disent
plus un écran 120 hertz en vain un
soulagement qui dirait 120 hertz
adaptatif alors pareil bové là un plat
tac tac tac vous allez dans l'affichage
et vous allez dans le taux de
rafraîchissement qui va être juste ici
taux de rafraîchissement automatique
vous allez là on vient pousser jusqu'à
120 hertz bon jusque là ça fonctionne
alors il faut savoir quand même qu'on
est en plein été on est à new york donc
fatalement la luminosité voyez que ça
fonctionne quand même pas mal alors il
ya différents modes notamment le mode
splendide ça je vous en avais déjà parlé
sur le z phone pour venir régler la
température de couleur régler les
couleurs de l'écran les celle par défaut
se trouve que pour ma part ça fonctionne
quand même déjà plutôt pas mal comme ça
un truc qui est intéressant c'est ce
qu'on va retrouver du côté du sort c'est
bon au delà des paramètres un peu rigolo
quand il ya un mode qui est pas mal à
celle monde extérieur je vais venir
pousser se sont beaucoup plus forts
enfin beaucoup un peu plus fort ce qu'il
faut savoir ici c'est qu'en fait comme
vous êtes sur un smartphone un peu
classique vous allez avoir d'autre part
leur l'acquis votre haut-parleurs
principal le deuxième qui arrive aux
parieurs d'emport est ce que nous a
raconté agissent là dessus c'est que en
fait ils font du travail et sur un mode
qui va venir compenser la différence
pour que vous visiez à sensation d'avoir
un signal plutôt symétrique qui vous
arrive enfin trop juste à dire dans même
chose le même niveau de volume de la
droite et la gauche sauf que dans les
faits c'est pas réellement ça vous avez
toujours cette différence de son qui
arrivent d'un côté là un peu plus fort
est ici un peu moins fort comme un
smartphone classique pas plus pas moins
par contre un truc qui est assez
intéressant ici c'est qu'ils nous ont
laissé une petite prise dit à qui ça
c'est un truc qui aime bien faire a
juste dans la mesure où ils peuvent vous
mettre une prise jack il vous met une
prise jack ça mange pas de pain ça prend
un peu de place à l'intérieur après ça
peut dire que c'est une prouesse parce
que vu la taille du truc venir trouver
de la place pour mettre une prise jack
c'est plutôt bien mais il ya beaucoup de
consommateurs qui aiment ça qu'ils le
veulent donc ça c'est intéressant et
puis comme on a également sur le roc
phone un partenariat avec d'irak pour
améliorer augmenter l'expérience audio
qui globalement comme ça et pas mal la
meilleure que vous aurez c'est quand
même avec un casque et à pouvoir trouver
des collègues de qualcomm la péter x
adaptative et la péter x lossless sans
oublier le stand rag and sand
[Musique]
côté performances on retrouve cinquième
mieux ça reste un dragon 8 jane one plus
c'est la dernière génération qui a gravi
par terry senseo var soit 8 soit 12 soit
16 giga de ram c'est de la télé hier 5
et puis côté stockage vous monter
jusqu'à 250 gigas de stockage non
extensible ici après y'a pas beaucoup de
place à l'intérieur qui est déjà très
très bien de 156 élus ffs trois points à
refroidissement par chambre à vapeur ou
québon très grand classique ça ira si
vous avez une petite batterie enfin
petit à lui paraît le monde cite une
batterie de 4300 millions terreur dans
la mesure où avec la plupart des
smartphones flagship pour des batteries
de 4500 4003 c'est bien mais ce n'est
que comme un smartphone qui est plutôt
petit en taille les plus grands le
samedi à quatre mais trois secteurs
c'est pas du tout petit puis vous avez
un chargeur de 30 watts inclus
directement dans votre boîte comme ça
vous pouvez le prendre avant de
l'acheter en plus ok mais si par contre
vous pas de recharge sans fil pendant
une fois de plus c'est une question de
taille ils n'ont pas eu la place pour
mettre la recharge sans fil à
l'intérieur si vous êtes ardue si vous
voulez vraiment de la recharge sans fil
très fort passez votre chemin et puis le
truc qui est intéressant c'est comme on
vous dit de la recharge 30 watts sec 30
watts apparaît assez rapide mais vu ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui avec de l'a 65 watts
de la sahwa 30 watts ça paraît pas
énorme ça va quand même assez vite il
faut savoir qu'il ya très peu de temps
samsung avec la 25 watts 30 watts ça
conviendra pour un rachat sera quand
même suffisamment vite bon ok pas de
mauvaise surprise d'être
[Musique]
ici l'expérience cni va ici c'est
quasiment de l'android pure on va
retrouver un tiroir d'application on va
venir retrouver tous ces paramètres sur
le haut qu'on peut venir customiser on
peut venir également dans ses paramètres
alors là j'ai un thème sombre vous
pouvez mettre un terme clair si vous le
voulez je vais te retrouver mon réseau
internet dont c'est très classique j'ai
pas vous faire l'affront de vous montrer
ça le seul truc qui peut être un peu
marrant c'est lorsque vous allez dans
fond d'écran est-il des cuistots misé
papier peint la couleur le style ça au
delà de ce côté là au delà de venir
customiser la police au delà de changer
la couleur du papier peint ça c'est et
matériels ou en fait 1 2 d'android pour
me retrouver ici vous avez le thème
clair le thème foncé il ya un autre truc
qui est un peu marrant c'est l'animation
est comme ça vous l'éteignez vous
l'allumez vous déverrouillez donc centre
qui fonctionne bien côté logiciel rien
truc que se tenir un peu reproché ici
lorsque je dis à utiliser mon smartphone
c'est lorsque je le mets voyez dans ce
sens là et que je vais venir zoomer
alors il ya un truc qui est assez
marrant cg le foie un essai le foie de
juste au dessus je peux appuyer sur le x
2 et savièse umeco côtoient donc ça
c'est assez marrant le seul truc qui est
un peu relou c'est qu'après il faut je
laisse appuyé et là je trouve que côté
molette et pas extrêmement pratique je
pense que j'aurais aimé avoir des petits
raccourcis en plus en retrait c'est
vraiment du chipotage du mec voiliers
qui a l'habitude d'utiliser des
smartphones on va jusqu'à info 8 mais
voilà sinon je trouve que l'idée plutôt
pas mal alors puisque dans la partie
photo je monte très rapidement d'un
point de vue logiciel il ya un autre
truc à venir voir sur la partie vidéo
vous venez là parce que je vais utiliser
l'enregistrement qui est hyper
stabiliser je peux le faire que jusqu'en
full hd si je veux ensuite monté en
4-4-2 précise sur le stabilisation
normal les huit cas il veut pas je pense
qu'il faut carrément je désactive tous
voila je vais faire les huit cas en 24
images par seconde sans hdr enfin c'est
tout cas connaître un petit peu agacé
petit point là parce que oui si on parle
de stabilisation parle de stabilisation
avec un bémol sur six axes mais si je
veux utiliser vraiment le mc de la
stabilisation c'est du full hd et après
pouvez regarder effectivement ça marche
bien c'est stabilisé 6 nouveaux civils
marque hyper sté vie active est fou que
ça marche vachement bien donc ça c'est
pour la partie stabilisation vidéo et
résolution vidéo
[Musique]
côté photo qu'est ce qu'on a ici à
l'arrière alors regardez vous avez deux
capteurs vous avez deux objectifs en
fait on va avoir du 50 méga pixels c'est
là sonia 1766 et le gros flagship le
gros capteur de sony le plus haut de
gamme donc ça c'est plutôt chouette sur
le papier on ouvre ici avec 20 points 9
et puis le deuxième c'est un ultra grand
temps où 12 mégapixels il ya 1363 f 2.2
pionner de la macro avec hockey de
l'arrière ça paraît bien pas la peine
d'en mettre plus il ya de plus en plus
de marques qui remettent en troisième
pour toujours un de ces bruits à new
york cède 1 il ya toujours des marques
qui veulent en mettre plus pourquoi pour
le côté marketing vous en adam troisième
faisant de la drague à très bientôt sur
un cinquième ça ne sert à rien
d'ailleurs fait une époque y avait une
marque que cet outil c'est qu'ils en
avaient sorti tellement que le produit
s'est jamais vendu il n'y avait pas que
pour sa trésorerie s'est jamais vendu
mais bon ça servait strictement rien ton
disque à l'avant alors autant essayer de
vous la montrer la est planqué justice
il a juste là vous avez une caméra 2
mégapixels caméra de cellfish ok trois
caméras sur le principe central bien
deux à l'arrière ils ont fait un bel
effort avec le flagship de chez sony
dynamique 766 ça c'est plutôt bien et on
va regarder l'état dans quelques
instants je vous montre les différents
modes qui existent ainsi sur votre
smartphone alors vous avez le mode
ralenti et bon qui très bon classique on
s'en fout l'intervalle de temps c'est un
time lapse ok la vidéo que vous avez
montré tout à l'heure la photo alors la
photo c'est aussi pas mal mode portrait
on peut venir choisir après son
ouverture voyez monte redescend hockey
le mode panorama sion lumineux ça vous
fait une espèce de traîner ça je les
utilisais la nuit vous montre le
résultat il ya différents effets
graffiti cascades circulation hockey et
après en plus vous allez avoir un mode
manuel en bonne nuit ou un mode pro
également est alors à prévenir
customiser vous prenez voulait s'appuyer
vous le descendez en bas si vous voulez
le truc est assez malin c'est pratique
permet de dire plus tôt misé hier ce
qu'il faut hier ce qui convient savard
seul truc vous le montre là vous l'avez
vu très rapidement qui est un peu relou
c'est que lorsque ma main elle vient
légèrement sur le côté il a glissé la
voyez sans faire exprès et bien ça
m'ouvre toute cette partie là donc
vraiment prendre l'habitude moi qui a
toujours traîné un peu mes mains sur le
côté ne pas faire ça parce que c'est un
peu relou c'est le seul truc alors si
avec tout ça c'est bien mais on se dit
pourquoi est-ce qu ici on appâte et
l'objectif avoir uniquement de capteurs
s'il coule mais il nous manque ce fameux
téléobjectif et aujourd'hui il ya de
plus en plus de constructeurs qui font
le choix comme ça ça ne pouvons pas nous
permettre de téléobjectifs ici moi
j'aurais bien aimé avoir un tel objectif
mais une fois de plus le vrai problème
le choix qu'a fait ici asus c'est la
compacité il n'y a pas la place de
mettre un tel objectif très clairement
vous l'avez pas ici vous avez des choix
qui sont opérés au niveau de la batterie
honni du processeur au niveau de tous
les composants vous à l'intérieur pour
avoir un petit smartphone avec quand
même deux très gros capteur est un
module photo qui est assez proéminent
sauraient pas pu en mettre un troisième
voilà j'ai passé pour vous c'est
rédhibitoire ne pas avoir tel objectif
par quelques mois d'ailleurs en barre
pour commentaire je vous montre le
résultat photo en commençant par les
photos de nuit alors là ici à new york
j'ai eu le temps de me balader et de
vous faire pas mal de petites images
vous allez voir je trouve que dans
l'ensemble il marche très très bien sûr
les photos de nuit alors sur l'ultra
grand temps que j'en ai fait mais une
fois de plus on sait très bien que les
smartphones sont les ultra grand-angle
c'est pas terrible donc on va oublier
même si on regarde un petit peu l'empiré
state building qui est juste derrière
c'est là où j'ai commencé la vidéo c'est
très très sympa comme endroit on a
toujours ses petits points au niveau des
lumières mais après à new york il ya
beaucoup de lumière donc je peux
comprendre que ça pose un peu le
problème ultra-grand-angle compass mais
dans l'ensemble vous allez voir je
trouve que le job est fait ça marche
bien même la du côté de chez massive
vers là je vous aime il est fait avec la
traînée de lumière que vous avez montré
sur la partie photo alors c'est rigolo
on peut faire des choses pour autant
faut-il réellement le faire je ne suis
pas convaincu la wilaya truc un peu
marrant il savoure cette dynamique de
vilains qui est très sympa une fois de
plus je vous le passez les au niveau de
la 6e avenue focus vraiment regarder les
photos de nuit elles sont cool elle
marche bien elles sont correctes et vu
le positionnement tarifaire du
smartphone en sort des choses qui sont
quand même vraiment très très sympa et
qui dans l'ensemble fonctionne vraiment
bien ok là on vient où mais très très
légèrement je voulais montrer au niveau
de la nuit oracle va tout de suite
beaucoup de bruit sur le bâtiment on
peut bien le faire on va éviter de faire
mais on peut venir le faire deux jours
les photos font sauf quand même plutôt
pas mal dans l'ensemble grand angle
ultra grand angle on peut venir jouer en
x 2 on monte quand x 10 6 8 6 et plus
exactement mais pas la peine d'aller
bien plus loin on va récupérer un peu
d'imprécisions mais c'est normal la
caméra de saïfi pas content d'elle même
je la trouve moins bien la gestion
d'autres lumières et 6 et moins bonnes
la peau va être beaucoup plus lisse et
c'est pas terrible par contre tout le
reste je trouve que vraiment ça fait une
halte à certains problèmes aussi au
niveau des hautes lumières vous le voyez
ici mais sinon dans l'ensemble le boulot
est plutôt pas trop mal c'est alors on
n'est pas sur le photophone ce n'est pas
parfait ici aussi beaucoup de lumière ça
est fatalement le smartphone mais dans
l'ensemble je trouve que le job est
plutôt bien fait même la une scène un
peu plus complexe que j'ai vraiment
beaucoup de lumière ici et là c'est pas
grand chose et bien s'en sort quand même
plutôt pas trop mal c'est pas parfait
une fois de plus un choix vraiment elle
précisé mais je trouve que vu le
positionnement tarifaire vu le boulot et
vu ce qui est proposé ici j'avais bien
fait même à contre jour comme ça voyons
on a quand même bien la façade de
l'immeuble on a bien l'immeuble derrière
bon voilà très beau boulot algorithmique
montre un petit peu on va voir un petit
écureuil et sinon new york voyez on
vient nous mais on peut sortir toute ma
rente donc voilà le job est plutôt bien
fait dans l'ensemble la même au niveau
de la bouffe alors ça c'est pas je n'ai
pas fait shooter avec la macro tu
préférais venir zoomer avec monthey
l'objectif trouver que le résultat était
quand même plutôt pas mal et c'est comme
ça mon ex sortira des choses un peu plus
sexy que vous reconnaissez style homme
ça vous dit quelque chose ou pas dites
le moi tout d'abord un commentaire c'est
un tout qui est très très connu dans new
york en fait c'est l'immeuble convoi
dans la série friends et qui situe au
niveau de greenwich village vous avez la
dre cela la voyez c'est au niveau de
groove nb est fort ce tweet groff une
belle forme stricte sur l'ultra grand
temps que six en arrache donc voilà je
vous montre un peu en dessous petite
balade une fois de plus on voit l'un
voyait la limite un peu lassé des hautes
lumières qu'on a ici là où il est un peu
des fois un peu de moyens la caserne des
60 hommes le one world trade center
comme ça on se fait vraiment du tourisme
on y va à fond c'est très joli come ca g
0 c'est un peu saturé un poil saturé ici
mais dans l'ensemble ok ça marche voyez
pas plat on peut venir shooter une fois
de plus la caméra de saïfi qui lis un
peu qu'ils aient pas dingue mais dans
l'ensemble voilà le résultat est là et
janis donne même sur des petites griffes
comme ça voyez une fois de plus c'est
pas de la macro et je suis désolé je
trouve ça mieux comme ça voilà comme ça
vous voyez un peu je vous montre en même
temps les vacances à new york ça c'est
chouette en termes de tarifs qu'est ce
que ça raconte ce smartphone alors j'ai
tout ici toutes mes notes tout m'est
arrivé sans doute très bien alors je
vous le dis il ya plusieurs confie on
est sur une version 828 à 799 euros
dispose normalement fin août noir blanc
rouge bleu on arrive sur une version 8
256 à se complexifie 849 euros
disponible en noir et blanc vous n'avez
pas le joli rouge que j'ai là et vous
avez la version 16 + 250 6 899 euros
uniquement ici en noir dispo mi août et
puis vous avez des prêts qu alors je
vous le dis en préco du 28 juillet au 28
août pendant un mois à partir du moment
où la vidéo sort quelque chose près vous
avez un accessoire support de sa cadeaux
offerts après inscription et acceptation
du dossier par asus se complexifier ya
un concours également pour gagner un
voyage et profiter dans un enfant de 9
ans d'explorations voilà ça ça se passe
yes je voulais un lien en bas dans la
description alors qu'est ce qu'on pense
qu'est ce que raconte ce smartphone ce
qu'il est intéressant à ce qu'il ait
fait pondre ce qu'il faut retenir ici
c'est que ça reste un smartphone pré ni
chez salah trois smartphones sous
android qui est correct les photos sont
correctes le rendu est correct si vous
voulez un petit format vous voulez pas
un truc très grand c'est probablement
l'un des smartphones qu'il vous faudra y
en a d'autres qui existe mais il ya très
peu donc ajuster ni sur une c'est un
smartphone très riche et mais qui est
plutôt pas mal l'écran est bien
l'expérience est bonne le smartphone et
un tarif qui est compétitif qui est
intéressante c'est pas le smartphone de
l'année il excelle nulle part il est
mauvais nul pas là où il est bon c'est
le petit format il ya un peu
d'innovation avec ce soleil sur le côté
est ce que ça suffit à venir lâche t il
la réponse est clairement non de
maintenant il est intéressant si vous
voulez un smartphone de la justice vous
voulez pas un smartphone chinoises sur
l'épais smartphones américains sous les
pins smartphone korian mais vous voulez
en smartphones taïwanais est bien celui
là peut venir vous faire l'oeil moi je
trouve intéressant plutôt pas mal
construit est ce que pour autant ils
vont en vendre énormément nous c'est
évident ce nom mais voilà ils ont fait
le choix du petit format et puis ils ont
très bien compris ça que l'on peut pas
se positionner face à tout le monde sur
le marché est ce qu'ils se disent ok le
marché va se réguler il ya beaucoup
d'acteurs il y en a qui vont se casser
la gueule y aura peut être moins de
références et dans quelques années on
vend sortir un peu plus où est ce qui se
dit çà sert à rien d'avoir des tonnes de
smartphone qu'on n'en proposera pour
montrer qu'on sait faire du smartphone
on sait faire du smartphone de guémy qui
est excellent qui pour moi est la
meilleure expérience avec leur iphone
ici on continue à être présent sur le
marché du smartphone sans forcément
espérer en vendre des tonnes à mon avis
un petit peu sale histoire la vérité est
un peu entre les deux sont très bons
dans le pays sont très bons dans plein
de domaines et là dessus ils sont
présents voilà même si j étais pas que
ça change vraiment la donne pour nous
non pour eux probablement en tout cas
c'est un smartphone qui est honnête qui
est bien christian bien qu'ils aient un
tarif très justes donc s'il vous
intéresse vous mets le lien juste en bas
dans la description et surtout vous
dites moi ce que vous en pensez ce que
vous savez les yeux dans les yeux parce
nous écoutent aussi on a new york est ce
que vous avez déjà eu un smartphone de
asus est ce que vous pourriez acheter un
smartphone jusqu'à ce que vous pensez de
la mare point de vue smartphones et est
ce que cette petite bête comme ça vous
l'aimez vous la trouvez jolie qu'est ce
que vous pensez du design moi je trouve
ainsi qu'annoncé jolie j'aime bien les
couleurs donc dites moi ce que vous en
pensez juste en bas en commentaire et
puis on se retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler de teck ici à new
york ou ailleurs ça c'est chouette vous
embrasse pour les penguins
[Musique]